دائما التذرع بانه لا يوجد شريك فلسطيني
قاله نتنياهو غير مره و وفي الواقع قالته
الاداره الامريكيه ايضا بالحديث عن ضروره
اصلاح السلطه
الفلسطينيه يعني ليس هنالك وجاهه في القول
بان هنالك مشكله ايضا في الجانب
الفلسطيني لا اسمح لي اولا يعني دعني اوضح
نقطه هنا اي اولا بايدن قال انه يمكن ان
يكون حل دولتين حتى في وجود نتنياهو طيب
خلينا نسمع من نتنياهو يخرج ويقول انه هو
يؤيد دوله فلسطينيه مستقله نتنياهو قال
قبل يومين فقط انه هو ضد قيام دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله ونتنياهو قال قبل اسبوع
انه افضل رئيس وزراء في اسرائيل لمنع قيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله اذا من نصدق واذا
كان بايدن صادق فليقل نتنياهو ذلك بلسانه
هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه ثانيه
الولايات المتحده على مدار ثلاث سنوات قبل
هذه هذه هذه الحرب التي بدات وبايدن يقول
نعم دوله حل الدولتين والى اخره ولكن ليس
الان الوقت غير مناسب
اي غريب ثالثا اذا كانت الولايات المتحده
تعترف بان الاستيطان يدمر امكانيه قيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله لماذا لا تضغط على
اسرائيل ولا بشيء ولا تهددها بشيء لوقف
الاستيطان على الاقل لوقف التوسع
الاستيطاني
كل هذا لا يحدث اما الحديث عن انه السبب
في عدم قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله انه لا
يوجد شريك فلسطيني فهذا ضلال لانه في
الواقع منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه اللي
وقعت اتفاق اوسلو واللي بيعترفوا فيها
كممثل الشاب الفلسطيني تستنى صار لها 30
سنه وخلال 30 سنه منذ عام 2014 لم يقبل اي
رئيس وزراء اسرائيلي ان يجتمع مع اي مسؤول
فلسطيني هذا خداع اسمه ثانيا ا اذا كانوا
هم مع وجود ممثل قوي للفلسطينيين لماذا
يرفضوا حل حق الشعب الفلسطيني في انتخابات
حره وديمقراطيه لماذا عارضت الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل حق الفلسطينيين المشروع
في اجراء انتخاباتهم الديمقراطيه عام
2021 ولماذا يواصلوا المعارضه اليوم لماذا
اعترضوا على حكومه الوحده الوطنيه التي
تشكلت عام 2007 والتي كانت تضم ممثلين من
جميع القوى التي انتخبت في البرلمان
الفلسطيني
دون استثناء الا الا فصيل واحد قطعها ولكن
كانت تمثل الجميع وقطعوها وحاصروها
واحتجزوا اموالها وظلوا يدفعوا بها حتى
سقطت هذا هو السؤال اذا كانوا يريدوا فعلا
ان يسمحوا للفلسطينيين بان يكون لهم ان
يكونوا شريق قوي فليسم فليواقعها انتخابات
حره وديمقراطيه وباي حق تريد الولايات
المتحده عندما تتحدث عن تجديد السلطه ماذا
تقصد سالنا عن ذلك اتضح انه كل اللي
بيحكوا عنه كيف يجعلوا السلطه سلطه امنيه
امنيه اكثر م ما هي عليه يعني الا يكفي ان
الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه تستهلك اكثر
من 40% من ميزانيه الد السلطه الفلسطينيه
شو بدهم كمان وهم يريدون جهاز امني ليعمل
مع اسرائيل لا يريد سلطه تمثل الشعب
الفلسطيني بشكل كامل وتمثل مصالح الشعب
الفلسطيني فالحديث عن التجديد انا استغرب
الولايات المتحده تتحدث عن في كل اقاع
المعموره عن الانتخابات الديمقراطيه وعن
حقوق الانسان والديمقراطيه الا عندما يصل
الامر لفلسطين يصبح انه على الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل ان تحدد من يقود
الفلسطينيين وهذا ما قاله بايدن حرفيا
عندما قال قبل حوالي شهر ونصف انه نحن
بحاجه الى سلطه فلسطينيه مقبوله لدى
اسرائيل باي حق هل نحن نشترط انه المنتخ
الذي ينتخب في اسرائيل يجب ان يكون مقبول
فلسطينيا كلام فارغ وبالتالي اذا كانت
النيه صادقه فليقولوا فلتعلم الولايات
المتحده ان من موافقتها على وقف اطلاق
النار فورا ولتعلن ان على اسرائيل وقف
الاستيطان فورا ولتقل لنا ما هي حدود
الدوله الفلسطينيه التي يتحدثون عنها ولا
بدنا نحكي عن مجرد كانتونات وجاتوهات
ومعاز وتبقى المستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه
اذا بقيت المستوطنات في الضفه الغربيه لا
يمكن ان تقوم دوله فلسطينيه مستقله هي هي
الاس الا التي يجب ان تطرح انا بكرر انا
اخشى انه كل هذا الحديث المضلل هدفه فقط
الوصول الى التطبيع مع المحيط العربي مره
اخرى على حساب القضيه الفلسطينيه وفي هذه
النقطه لا يختلف بايدن عن ترامب
بشيء وهل تعتقد انه الحديث الان عن هذا
هذا هذا المسار هو كما قلت لا اطلاق مسار
التطبيع
ايضا اعتقد ذ نعم انا اعتقد ان هذا ما
يريده بايدن يريد اطلاق مسار التطبيع على
امل ان يساعد ذلك في الانتخابات القادمه
بعد ان شعر الان انه على وشك الهزيمه
غالبيه الشعب الامريكي ضد سياسته وغالب
الشباب الامريكي ضد سياسته وهو خسر جزء
كبير من الناخبين الذين انتخبوه في المره
الماضيه وسيخسر في الانتخابات القادمه هو
يريد ان يقدم شيء على انه انجاز
للفلسطينيين ليقنع المجموعات التي ستق
سواء كانوا العرب والمسلمين واللاتينيين
والافارقه وغيرهم انه حقق شيء للفلسطينيين
ويبقى هذا الشيء مجرد شيء لفظي لا قيمه له
في التطبيق العملي وفي نفس الوقت يريد ان
ياخذ اصوات اليهود هذا ما يسعى اليه ويلعب
لعبه انا برايي في لعبه فيها شيء كثير
كبير من التضليل في الواقع شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي امين عام المبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه